[Musique]
hu
donald trump toujours hospitalisé à
l'hôpital militaire walter reed à
washington le président des états unis
aurait des difficultés à respirer
il est traité au reine des civières et
or générons un traitement expérimental
le chef de la maison blanche qui a reçu
des messages de soutien des chefs d'état
du monde entier
sa compagne électorale est à l'arrêt son
rival démocrate vous souhaite un prompt
rétablissement
[Musique]
des nouvelles restrictions attendu
demain en france une semaine après
marseille l'exécutif pourrait imposer
des mesures plus strictes à paris et en
banlieue qui devrait basculer en zone d'
alerte maximale
l approche des fêtes de la toussaint les
hôpitaux parisiens envisagent d'annuler
les congés de leur personnel
plusieurs syndicats appellent à la grève
le 15 octobre prochain
ils demandent des ouvertures de lits
massive toujours de violents combats
dans le nagorny karabakh l'arménie par
le même de la dernière bataille selon
son ministère de la défense les
militaires de cette zone autoproclamé
serait parvenu à stopper une attaque
d'ampleur de l'armée azérie la russie se
dit toujours préoccupé par la possible
présence de combattants pro turc envoyés
du moyen-orient
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce samedi l'inquiétude à
washington après l'hospitalisation de
donald trump pourra-t-il se présenter ou
pas à l'élection du 3 novembre prochain
alors qu'il a été transféré vous voyez
hier soir à l'hôpital militaire de
walter reed à washington avec des
difficultés à respirer
ces médecins assurent aujourd'hui qu'il
va très bien qu'il n'est pas sous
assistance respiratoire et qu'il n'a pas
de fièvre
le président américain a confirmé dans
un tweet ce que ses médecins ont dit en
conférence de presse regarder les
médecins les infirmières et tout le
monde de l'hôpital walter reed et
d'autres institutions tout aussi
incroyable qui les ont rejoints sont
incroyables grâce à eux je me sens bien
ils bénéficient de soins
pluridisciplinaires exceptionnelle à la
pointe de la science pour l'infection
coronavirus nous suivons son état de
santé de très près pour déceler tout
signe de complications dues à la maladie
ou aux thérapies que nous prescrivons
pour le soigner nous avons suivi son
activité cardiaque sa fonction rénale sa
fonction hépatique qui sont tout
normales et le président n'est pas sous
assistance respiratoire ce matin qu'il
n'a pas de difficulté à respirer ou à
marcher dans l'unité médicale de la
maison blanche laitages
il est d'une humeur exceptionnels est en
réalité alors que nous terminons nos
visites pluridisciplinaire ce matin il
nous a quittés en disant j'ai
l'impression que je pourrais sortir
d'ici aujourd'hui ce qui est un
commentaire très encourageant de la part
du président le chef de la maison
blanche qui a reçu des messages du monde
entier et même de son rival démocrate
qui lui est qui lui a souhaité un prompt
rétablissement
écoutez joe biden je voudrais commencer
et je suis sûr que vous vous joindrez à
moi par adresser mes prières pour la
santé et la sécurité de la première dame
et du président des états unis après
qu'ils ont été testés positifs au co
vite 19
mon épouse jill et moi même avons prié
pour qu'il se rétablisse
si tu es complètement c'est un vif
rappel pour nous tous que nous devons
prendre ce virus au sérieux il ne va pas
s'en aller lui-même
nous devons assumer notre part et être
responsable
cela signifie suivre la science écouter
les experts nous laver les mains
respectez la distanciation physique
cela signifie porter un masque dans les
deux publics et encourager les autres à
en faire de même aux joueurs donald
trump va bien donc à en croire ses
médecins pourtant des journalistes
accrédités à la maison blanche donne une
version contradictoire citant une source
en off les signes vitaux de donald trump
serait très inquiétant il n'y aurait pas
de voix claire vers leur établissement
le président américain qui est donc
rattrapé par cette maladie qu'il avait
tendance à minimiser il ya à peine
quelques jours encore lucas tueur donald
trump l'affirmé en février dernier le
coronavirus n'est pas pire que la grippe
il disparaîtra avec la hausse des
températures au printemps huit mois plus
tard c'est un sérieux coup du destin
pour le locataire de la maison blanche
ce soir la première dame et moi avons
été testé positif aux qu'ovide 19
nous commençons immédiatement notre
processus de quarantaine et de
récupération
nous traverserons cette épreuve ensemble
donald trump et les risques liés aux
kobe 19 c'est une histoire compliquée
dès l'apparition du virus le président
américain avait clairement annoncé qu'il
ne porterait pas de masque dénonçant un
comportement alarmiste de la part des
instances médicales et de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
pourtant avec un poids officiel de 110
kg une tension artérielle à surveiller
et un faible revendiquer pour la
nourriture grasse le président de 74 ans
ferait partie des gens les plus à risque
selon de nombreux médecins
il a fallu attendre mi juillet pour que
donald trump change d'avis notamment sur
le port du masque un virage à 180° en 24
heures je veux que les gens est une
certaine liberté et je ne suis pas
d'accord avec l'affirmation selon
laquelle si tout le monde met un masque
qui tout va disparaître
nous sommes unis dans nos efforts pour
vaincre cet invisible ville
chinois beaucoup de gens disent que
c'est un acte patriotique de porter un
masque quand la distance physique ne
peut être maintenue il n'y a pas plus
patriotes que moi votre président
préféré la contamination kovy 19 tombe
très mal pour le président américain
candidat à sa réélection
il doit aujourd'hui annulée et tous ses
meetings une mauvaise nouvelle pour ses
partisans qu'ils s'apprêtaient à
l'applaudir en floride ce samedi dans le
wisconsin dimanche en géorgie lundi et
en arizona mardi et mercredi
il aurait pu être contaminé par une de
ses plus proches collaboratrices aux
pics testée positive à un peu plus tôt
et qui avait accompagné donald trump à
cleveland pour le débat télévisé contre
joe biden un débat pendant lequel donald
trump s'était moqué de son adversaire
démocrate pour avoir fréquemment porter
un masque depuis le début de sa campagne
si l'état du président était amené à se
dégrader et c'est le vice président mike
pence qui assurait alors l'intérim
une situation qui s'est déjà produite
aux etats unis pendant quelques heures
sous ronald reagan et sous george bush
junior et forcément toutes les
spéculations vont bon train voyez ce
qu'en dit andré bercoff journaliste et
auteur de donald trump
les raisons de la colère aujourd'hui je
pense que la situation si elle ne
s'attarde pas sienne le dur par profil à
donald trump dans la sens audi bon même
lui avec ce côté un peu brayard un peu
un peu comme ça
comment dirais-je très la jourre macho
et compagnie il dit bob gainey comme les
autres il doit frapper ça ça n'empêche
pas kilos qu'il est aux manettes et
qu'il continue ça peut jouer pour lui en
revanche a en revanche si effectivement
sur votre question si le débat du 15
octobre n'a pas lieu
je crois que c'est très très mal barré
c'est évident parce qu elles sont là
pour
pour la majorité des américains et du
monde ça veut dire qu'il sera il ne sera
pas capable de reprendre des affaires
avec avec la force et l'acuité qu'on lui
que l'essai quel que soit ce qu'on peut
penser de 30
il était là et il il avait une énergie à
revendre si effectivement il est malade
et que cette énergie banque
cela va jouer contre lui de façon
drastique c'est clair
un point sur la situation sanitaire en
france 12148 nouveaux cas de coronavirus
détecter ces dernières 24 heures un taux
de positivité estimée à 7,7 pour 148
décès de plus ce qui porte à plus de
32000 le nombre de morts depuis le début
de la pandémie
c'est le dernier bilan qui a été
rapporté par l' agence santé publique
france et le personnel hospitalier
français qui lui est inquiet à la proche
des fêtes de la toussaint les hôpitaux
parisiens envisagent d'annuler les
congés de leur personnel plusieurs
syndicats et collectifs appellent à la
grève le 15 octobre prochain
ils demandent des ouvertures de lits
massive voyez ce qu'on dit anne claire
rafflegeau elle est infirmière et membre
du collectif inter agences au delà de du
manque de matériel qu'on qui est assez
récurrent mais je l'espère qui sera
quand même au rendez vous 6 1
s'il ya vraiment une augmentation des
cas et qu'il ya une réelle deuxième
vague
ce qui m'inquiète le plus c'est le
risque de contamination chez les croit
les soignants ce qui va entraîner des
arrêts maladie est également des burnout
ce qu on a quand même des soignants qui
sont clairement au bout du rouleau
on peut le voir sur les commentaires sur
twitter nous sur les commentaires de
notre site internet ou de nos réseaux
sociaux les gens le disent et et on a
peur que justement on n'y soit pas au
rendez-vous et de manquer cruellement de
personnel à marseille les bars et les
restaurants sont toujours fermés le
ministre de la santé s'est entretenu
hier avec les élus locaux
olivier verrons qui assure qu'il n'ya
aucune différence de traitement entre
aix marseille et d'autres grandes
métropoles
kirill kotick of prévenir pour mieux
guérir au risque de voir la béraud périr
bref de mauvais calembours
que se passe-t-il à marseille pourquoi
les mesures sanitaires drastiques qui
étouffe actuellement le monde de la
restauration dans la cité phocéenne
continue d'être appliquée alors que
d'autres grandes villes françaises y
échappe depuis quatre jours consécutifs
les réanimations ne cesse de baisser
dans la deuxième ville de france passant
de 50 à 39 sur 90 lits un signe
encourageant qui aurait pu amener le
ministre de la santé olivier veyrat a
levé la fermeture des bars dans les
bouches du rhône
pourtant lors de son point de situation
du 1er octobre il n'en a rien été
dans cette zone nous prenons du coup par
nécessité des mesures de gestion plus
contraignantes encore pour freiner plus
vite et plus fort la circulation virale
nous ciblons précisément les milieux et
les circonstances à risque en
interdisant les grands rassemblements
cette fois ci au dessus de 1000
personnes s'appuyant sur les données du
système d'information national le cidep
le président du conseil général de la
région paca le républicain renaud
muselier le faisait remarquer le 1er
octobre même le fameux taux d'incidence
qui indique la force de propagation
d'une épidémie est en forte baisse sous
les 200 personnes par 100 mille
habitants désormais
et pourtant les bars de la métropole aix
marseille restent fermés tandis qu'ils
sont toujours ouverts à paris où le taux
d'incidence est plus fort dans sa
dernière vidéo datant du mardi 29
septembre le professeur et
épidémiologiste marseillais didier
rahout notait de son côté une tendance
de l'épidémie à la baisse dans la cité
phocéenne comme on la même tendance
c'est à dire qu'elles sont une courbe
c'est une courbe en cloche aussi on est
sur la pente descendante de la cloche
qu'il s'agisse des cas détecté des cas
hospitalisés
l'augmentation des admissions en
réanimation ces derniers jours n'était
donc selon lui que le reflet de ce qu'il
se passait il ya dix douze jours se
basant sur les travaux du professeur
parisien vincent jarlier didier rahout
note par ailleurs une différence notable
de la sévérité de l'épidémie au niveau
de la mortalité
or le problème c'est qu'olivier ferrand
dans son point d'actualité du 1er
octobre présente des chiffres différents
aix marseille i est toujours présenté
avec un taux d'incidence a plus de 250
contrairement à paris alors que d'après
le système d'information nationale celle
inverse
autre point crispant le taux
d'occupation des lits de réanimation
dans les bouches du rhône
il est de 40 4% tandis qu'il avoisine
les 45 50 voire 55 % dans le val d'oise
la seine et marne et la seine saint
denis où le bar reste pourtant toujours
ouvert et il faut dire que ces jeux de
chiffres passent mal pour les élus
provençaux ces restrictions sont vécus
comme de lourdes sanctions économiques
infligé un secteur de la restauration
déjà très fragile autant dire comme une
véritable injustice
olivier ferrand s'est pris les pieds
dans le tapis et ne sait pas comment
pouvoir s'en sortir et décisions prises
à marseille ne peuvent pas être prises
dans le reste de la france
je lui demande de changer de position à
marseille on est en souffrance
économique
olivier ferrand a puni ceux qui ont fait
le plus d'efforts en matière de coded en
france ce soir au vu des chiffres des
courbes et de l'absence totale de
nouvelles mesures dans le pays je note
qu olivier verront se soucie finalement
plus de la situation sanitaire à
marseille qu'à paris ou qu'à lille les
marseillais le remercier
le 30 septembre à 15 heures le tribunal
administratif a confirmé le droit du
gouvernement à garder les restaurants et
les bars fermés dans les bouches du
rhône
pourquoi donc ces différences de
traitement entre les bouches-du-rhône et
l'île de france
pourquoi le gouvernement annonce t'il
des chiffres différents de ceux des
sources officielles disponibles
publiquement
dans les alpes-maritimes au moins huit
personnes actuellement portées disparues
après les fortes intempéries d'hier une
centaine de maisons ont été emportées
des ponts et des routes détruit de
nombreux villages de l'arrière pays
niçois restent inaccessibles à les crues
qui ont provoqué vous voyez plusieurs
glissements de terrain ainsi que des
éboulements
le premier ministre s'est dit très
inquiète sur le bilan de ce déluge
écoutez le
je ne vous cache pas notre vive
inquiétude sur le bilan définitif de cet
épisode
mes pensées vont aussi à l'ensemble des
forces de secours et de sécurité engagés
pour faire face à cette catastrophe 871
dont 204 en renforcent encore une fois
celles-ci sont durement éprouvée avec
deux sapeurs pompiers disparus
un capitaine et un sapeur pompier
volontaire
et puis sachez que à la frontière
franco-italienne quatre allemands et 18
italiens sont toujours portées disparues
après des pluies diluviennes
mobilisation des gilet jaune aujourd'hui
des rassemblements qui ont eu lieu
devant les locaux des grands médias à
paris les manifestants qui dénoncent une
fois de plus selon eux le nom de
pluralisme dans la presse et
l'influencent des grands groupes
économiques sur ces médias les médias
télévisés ne font pas leur rôle
on va dire de chercheurs de vérité
d'enquêteurs et ils devraient ils sont
trop acoquiné avec le gouvernement et
manipulé justement par ce gouvernement
et par les lois
je sais pas en fait ils ne se posent pas
de question ne se pose pas de vraies
questions sur le bien-fondé que ce soit
des lois et la cohérence de ce qu'on
leur fait dire chaque jour ça change
voilà depuis le début mars que ce soit
avec la crise du duc au vide et même
avant enfin voilà avec les lois retraite
donc nous on a été ridiculisé fait
passer pour des séditieux des factieux
des violents des antisémites ou des
fachos tout a été fait pour nous diviser
et nous ridiculiser face
face à la population française c'est
comme ça que notre mouvement gilet jaune
qui a été un mouvement pour le bien
commun a un peu diminué
une journée d'action également en france
pour réduire le trafic aérien une
quarantaine de militants écologistes ont
été interpellés ce matin après s'être
introduits sur le tarmac de l'aéroport
roissy charles de gaulle des militants
qui sont entrés par effraction vers 9
heures en passant par une clôture
ils ont ensuite été bloqués par les
forces de l'ordre ou du terminal 2a
ils n'ont pas pu accéder aux pistes
selon une source policière ont coûté
leurs revendications cette action pour
nous elle est essentielle parce qu'il
faut aujourd'hui faire en sorte que le
secteur ait rien se soumettent lui aussi
à l'impératif climatique et participe à
l'effort collectif de lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
aujourd'hui le secteur aérien on estime
que c'est au moins 7 % de l'empreinte
carbone de la france et surtout ça va
augmenter à l'avenir dès lors que cette
crise sanitaire va être terminée on sait
que les créoles les compagnies aériennes
se prépare à relancer d'innombrables
avions dans le ciel et que ce secteur-là
va peser de plus en plus dans l'équation
le climatique il faut réduire
aujourd'hui et supprimer les vols courts
dès lors qu'il ya des alternatives entre
impossible il faut faire en sorte que le
secteur aérien soit moins impactant sur
le pour le climat et l'environnement
on lutte contre les extensions
d'aéroport on n'est pas opposé au trafic
aérien
on est opposé à la croissance infinie
est folle de ce trafic nous emmène dans
le mur c'est également la raison pour
laquelle on fait partie du collectif
opposé à la construction du terminal 4
qui est prévu par adp qui représenterait
l'équivalent de orly et roissy le
secteur de l'aviation essaye de nous
faire croire qu'il est porteur d'
énormément d'emplois qui les préserve
alors qu'on voit qu air france vient de
bénéficier d'un plan à hauteur de 7
milliards et qu'en parallèle il annonce
7 me licenciement donc on voit
qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises n'ont
qu'une intérêt il ne cherche pas à
protéger leurs employés en italie le
procès de matteo salvini l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur était prévu
aujourd'hui il a été reporté au 20
novembre prochain la justice italienne
qui souhaite d'abord entendre le premier
ministre giuseppi comptait avant de se
prononcer sur un éventuel renvoi de son
ministre de l'intérieur
la matteo salvini qui est accusé d'abus
de pouvoir être séquestration personnes
les faits reprochés remontent souvenez
vous à l'été dernier ils avaient bloqué
pendant plusieurs jours un navire des
garde-côtes italiens avec à son bord 116
grands des accusations qualifiées d'
inappropriée par matteo salvini mettre
en accusation un ministre qui a fait ce
qu'il avait promis de faire et le faire
en appliquant la loi est quelque chose
d'assez particulier
je prends toute la solidarité possible
et j'ai confiance que mes juges feront
leur travail tranquillement calmement et
rapidement
quelle est la frontière entre une
décision officielle du gouvernement et
le travail des tribunaux
il s'agit d'un précédent qui ne concerne
pas seulement salvini demain il pourrait
y avoir le ministre de l'éducation des
transports ou de l'aide sociale qui
pourrait être jugé pour ses choix
politiques
c'est quelque chose de dangereux il est
dangereux de jugés dans un tribunal
un choix politique l'allemagne célèbre
sa fête nationale aujourd'hui 30 ans
après la réunification au cours d'une
manifestation à berlin des heurts ont
éclaté entre les forces de l'ordre et
des manifestants anti fasciste d'autres
rassemblements
ont été organisées simultanément par le
mouvement néonazi la troisième voie la
chancelière allemande a appelé les
allemands à faire preuve du même courage
que lors de la chute de l'allemagne de
l'est face à la pandémie du coronavirus
nous savons qu'aujourd'hui nous devons
être à nouveau courageux courageux
d'emprunter de nouvelles voix face à une
pandémie
courage ou de surmonter réellement les
différences qui subsistent entre l'est
et l'ouest mais aussi courageux d'exiger
les deux vrais pour la cohésion de toute
notre société
encore et toujours un autre faisceau à
rennes 7e jour de violents combats
consécutifs entre l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie dans le haut-karabakh
l'arménie qui fait état aujourd'hui de
51 soldats tués dans la république
autoproclamée
ce qui porte le bilan total à 242 morts
de chaque côté
l'arménie qui est selon elle à un moment
décisif de son histoire selon son
premier ministre
il s'est dit ouvert au dialogue pour
discuter d'un cessez le feu hier
de son côté le porte-parole de l'armée
de la république autoproclamée du haut
karabagh accusé l'azerbaïdjan de prendre
les civils pour cible écoutez les demies
continue de violer toutes les lois
écrites et non écrite de la guerre
frappant les zones habitées au plus
profond des lignes arrières aujourd'hui
ces zones civiles sont sous les tirs
d'artillerie y compris des tirs de
roquettes sur des cibles civiles dans la
capitale stepanakert et la présidente de
la géorgie pays voisins a essayé
d'envoyer un message aux donations pour
raisonner les gouvernements à tenter en
tout cas de les inciter à instaurer un
cessez-le-feu dictée médoc hambourg 3
vraiment très bas
je tiens à exprimer mes sincères
condoléances aux victimes du conflit
entre nos deux nations voisines et amies
linda lee martin à regniowez mégots par
adam et obélix presidents' d'arcalis où
je veux exhorté les présidents et les
gouvernements de nos voisins et amis à
rétablir le dialogue désamorcer la
situation et instaurer un cessez le feu
et à sang c'est le principal intérêt de
nos nations apporter à cette région la
stabilité la paix et son énorme rôle
économique stable robin ces daubes à
table ici et quand on met au lit aux
hasards rôles et la stabilité de cette
région du haut-karabakh et bien sûr
essentielle sur points économiques et
stratégiques
voyez ce qu'on dit aline papa devions
aller chargé de cours à l'université
d'aix marseille et auteur de l'ouvragé
l'arménie à l'épreuve du feu l'intérêt
du président français se situe à
plusieurs niveaux d'abord il est évident
qu'une déstabilisation plus en plus que
ce qui est en cours aujourd'hui au sud
caucase est extrêmement dangereuse pour
l'europe le sud caucase est tout de même
en partenariat avec l'europe par le
partenariat oriental et l'arménie fait
partie de ce partenariat un degré
relativement poussée donc le la france
en tant que pays européens ne veut pas
d'une région déstabilisée dans cet
endroit là il y avait évidemment des
liens d'amitié des liens commerciaux
avec l'arménie mais aussi avec
l'azerbaïdjan très très forte des liens
stratégiques
puisqu'il ya des entreprises françaises
qui sont engagés par la vente
d'armements en azerbaïdjan en kz1
rappelant le passage et la france est en
excellente position pour être médiatrice
puisque comme je vous le disais par le
biais du groupe de minsk à la fil des
années construit une position de
relative impartialité
aujourd'hui la france dénonce clairement
que l'attaquant cours est une attaque
menée par l'azerbaïdjan et que la partie
arménienne ici est en position de
défense et que par ailleurs le rôle de
la turquie est délétère
au soudan la signature d'un accord de
paix aujourd'hui entre le pouvoir et les
groupes rebelles un traité de paix qui
doit officiellement mettre un terme à 17
années de guerre dans ce pays mais des
incertitudes demeurent quant à son
application
voyez les explications en images
[Musique]
on
nous
le
[Musique]
cet exode massif de milliers de
honduriens qui font route vers les etats
unis le président du guatemala a ordonné
l'arrestation de ces migrants le mexique
a déployé des militaires le long de sa
frontière
mais pas de quoi les les dissuader vous
allez le voir grégoire douce est une
véritable caravane humaine ils seraient
environ 3000 à avoir passé la frontière
entre le honduras et le guatemala non
sans difficulté parti en milieu de
semaine depuis san pedro sula deuxième
ville du pays ils quittent leur terre
d'origine dans le but de rejoindre les
états unis et d'y trouver des conditions
de vie plus favorable mais aucune
certitude d'y parvenir puisqu'il faut
pour cela traverser deux pays
le guatemala et le mexique sans se faire
arrêter après un accueil hostile dans le
premier certains ont décidé de
rebrousser chemin
d'autres restent déterminés comment
on a pris la décision de rentrer parce
que la situation est très compliquée sur
le passage de la frontière entre le
guatemala et le mexique
malgré ce qu'a dit le président
guatémaltèque
nous allons continuer notre chemin les
autorités guatémaltèques et mexicaines
ne voit en effet pas d'un bon oeil
l'arrivée de ces milliers de personnes
qui ont vu la crise sanitaire empire et
leurs conditions de vie déjà délicate
l'ordre a été donné d'arrêter tous ceux
qui sont entrés illégalement sur le
territoire guatémaltèques et de les
ramener à la frontière de leur pays pour
les remettre aux autorités honduriennes
des ondulations tester la soulte au
québec
c'est une question qui je pense est lié
aux élections américaines
notez motors element pellan je n'ai pas
tous les éléments mais certaines choses
montre que cela s'est formé dans ce but
de quai et sterger allemand connaissez
je ne sais pas qui ça profite à
bénéficier des kings
s'ils parviennent au bout de ce long
périple c'est hondurien seront
confrontés à la stricte politique
migratoire mise en place par le
président des états unis donald trump
à moins que les élections américaines du
3 novembre prochain ne change la donne
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité on se retrouve dans 30
minutes rester avec vous
d
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coupe
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]